good morning John it's Friday so we've
been doing this stuff for eight years
now on you too hello there hi corndog hi
huh yeah hmm okay that was weird I the
universe apparently wants me to do
something not in this chair and with
these books
I remember when I was a young man my
mama took me to the store 125 seven
years but no reason to stop there
professor Jim likes you do
55 centimeters everybody 155 centimeters
now let's go for another level because
you can't build a giant tower and just
leave it there you have to see how far
you can go okay look at Merlin is on
which opens up the opportunity for
another thing to get stacked on here
well it had to happen the question is
can you beat me so first I want to
apologize for the amount of underwear
that I showed while constructing my book
tab that was both unintentional and
embarrassing but I'm certainly not gonna
go rebuild an entire book tower just so
I can go put on a belt and do it so that
you don't see the clothes that happened
to cover up my bond second I made a book
tower that was a hundred and fifty five
centimeters tall and I believe that that
is not as tall as a book tower can be so
I would like you to beat me the five
highest towers and the five most stylin
towers will win a special gift package
sent directly to your house from me
rules you cannot use any kind of
adhesive or clamps or anything that
binds the books together it has to be
composed of loose books rule number two
you cannot hurt yourself or do anything
that might cause you to hurt yourself
please read you can only use books but
you can pull together books from
multiple sources or you have to have a
tape measure and you have to measure in
centimeters because inches are dumb and
I cannot believe that we still use any
kind of measurement system that is not
based on the numerical system that we
use a base 10 base 12 why are there 12
inches in a foot to enter it send a
picture of your book tower with a
subject book tower and then the height
of your book tower in the subject line
to Hank and John a gmail guy
and lastly it is time for the
nerdfighteria census this will be the
third annual we've been doing it since
2013 and the idea is just so that the
community can get to know itself better
know what it is know who it is I can do
an analysis know what you want from this
we can better plan any future tours that
we might do so that we know where people
are or lives here for the first time we
actually talked to some researchers who
are doing some science and we had them
put in a few questions which will help
them better understand the world of the
people
so that's cool it's not an insignificant
thing it takes a little while to do like
10 to 30 minutes but we really
appreciate it when people do do that and
there's a link in the description if you
want to go and do it so thank you we
appreciate that looking forward to
seeing all your book towers and John
I'll see you on Tuesday